[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui chacun de
nous a une opportunité sans précédent
des contribué à la documentation la
sauvegarde du patrimoine
j'ai la chance de pouvoir vous parler de
ça ici à avignon une ville qui est connu
dans le monde entier pour son patrimoine
culturel
il suffit de sortir de cette salle pour
être immergé dans un univers d'histoire
d'architecturé d'art des traditions
c'est un héritage qui se transmet d'une
génération à l'autre et nous faisons
tous partie cette chaîne de transmission
car le patrimoine représente en tant
qu'individu en tant que groupe en tant
que communauté en tant que société
ce patrimoine est souvent fragile
menacer d'un disparaître à cause de son
âge de son état de conservation du
nombre élevé les touristes qui visitent
bien sûr à cause de catastrophes
naturelles
il suffit de penser au tremblement de
terre en italie les mots dernier c'est
la raison pour laquelle la conservation
et la restauration du patrimoine
mobilise les états les organismes
internationaux
si bien que les collectivités
territoriales et nous tous simples
citoyens l'ignorance les guerres les
conflits sont également une menace pour
ce patrimoine
voyez nous sommes toujours frappée par
des images de destruction c'est surtout
parce que nous pensons à ces objets
comme si s'était figé dans les temps la
réalité c'est que nous observons
aujourd'hui n'est qu'un état transitoire
de la vie de ces objets qui sont
constamment fait d'effets rey fait au
fil des événements historiques qui les
traversent
c'est bien le cas de nombreux sites
archéologiques comme palmyre qu'avant
d'être détruit par des chats avaient été
déjà remonté quand suite à des
destructions et dégradations intérieur
lacoste
si on est la mémoire d'un patrimoine ses
bases sur une perpétuelle
réinterprétation du passé mais parce que
ces objets possède des valeurs pour
leurs caractéristiques physiques mais
aussi et surtout pour ce qui est des
présentes et c'est qu'il représente et
construit jour après jour grâce à notre
regard collectif sur le passé et sur
l'avenir à la fois c'est à dire sur les
choix des transmissions que nous faisons
aux prochaines générations et même les
modalités et des transmissions évolué
paris dans les temps car elles répondent
à une société qui est toujours en
devenir
aujourd'hui à l'âge du numérique
nous sommes constamment immergées dans
des flux d'information des informations
que l'on d'être simplement transmises
aurait su comment ça s'est matérialisée
dans de nouveaux lieux le web les
réseaux sociaux j'ai bien dit
matérialiser parce que il ya bien une
matérialité numérique qui commence à
traverser plusieurs dimensions de notre
quotidien
et bien c'est dans ce quotidien que nous
devons faire les choix de transmission
aux générations futures
depuis une trentaine d'années le
numérique a permis des avancées
extraordinaires dans la documentation du
patrimoine il suffit de penser aux
technologies pour numériser en 3d des
objets d'art ou des monuments ou encore
les logiciels qui permettent d'analyser
de d'interagir ou de visualiser ses
contenus ou des systèmes qui permet de
mémoriser donner accès à du texte des
images et du son à des vidéos des
modèles 3d ou encore des systèmes qui
nous permettent aujourd'hui de
s'immerger dans des institutions virtuel
les images que vous voyez à l'écran
montre des moments du projet de
recherche que mon laboratoire encore
donné sur le pont d'avignon
des carottages géologique jusqu'aux
sources écuries fixe ancien des
échographies sous marine jusqu'au
plongée dans les archives historiques
des nuages des points 3d issus d'un
balayage laser ou par ron jusqu'au la
constitution hypothétique il ya toute
une communauté des chercheurs qui se
réunit autour de la modélisation
numérique qui formalise aujourd'hui et
synthétise les informations des
connaissances sur les origines les
transformations du pont saint bénézet un
ouvrage que tout en étant bien connue
d'un point de vue touristique resté
méconnu sur le plan historique
la modélisation numérique a été pendant
tous ces projets quelque chose tu as eu
lieu il brille de mille ans le rhin le
virtuel qui a permis à cette communauté
de se retrouver dès croiser le regard
pluridisciplinaire est de reconnecter
des centaines des fragments
d'informations sur le plan spatial
temporel et conceptuel je me souviens de
séances de travail où on réunissait des
archéologues des historiens des
architectes des géomorphologue des
ingénieurs des informaticiens de toutes
tranches d'âge ont démarré d'un croquis
sur un cahier on traduisait les
boucliers un modèle 3d un modèle 3d
le modèle tron a été ensuite traduit en
images 2d on envoyait ces images par
email à des collègues mes collègues
maires et cv les imprimés pour pouvoir y
est vrai dessinée au dessus au crayon et
quelques semaines plus tard on rêvait
ces images au laboratoire par la poste
là on va numériser et on veut projeter
tous ces informations sur la maquette 3d
était une expérience extraordinaire
je vous donne quelques chiffres 50
kilomètres carrés de territoire
cartographier étudier et restituées par
des centaines de numérisation qui ont
donné lieu à plus de 6 milliards des
coordonnées 3d penser que pour calculer
les images que vous voyez à l'écran on a
dû employer un réseau des 480
processeurs mais c'est pas si vous
rendez compte
j'ai quatre processeurs de machines
perso je vais vous donner les chiffres
les plus impressionnants 3200 ce sont
les emails que les membres de ces
projets ont changé pendant le projet
bien que c'est le chiffre le plus
important car au delà du niveau de
sophistication des images des
technologiques et les élabore ses biens
ses systèmes d'interaction humaine c'est
bien ce système des croisements
d'observation et des regards qui permet
d'utiliser le numérique dans une
démarche de production des connaissances
si vous y pensez bien c'est toujours une
combinaison de regard qui nous permet de
voir les choses de découvrir des choses
dans ces projets tous ces regards
étaient orientés vers un objet
patrimonial d'exception ce qui a aussi
justifié l'emploi d'un dispositif
technologique d'exception mais si on
fait abstraction de la technologie on
peut facilement réaliser que ces
croisements de regards concerne bien et
pourrait concerner davantage tous les
objets patrimoniaux qui nous entoure
tous les objets patrimoniaux qui nous
entoure c'est certainement facile à dire
mais déjà avez vous une idée de
l'ampleur du domaine patrimonial a
documenté bien savez-vous déjà combien
d'objets d'intérêt historique on peut
compter en sortant de cette salle en se
promenant centre-ville
aussi le plan d'avignon le pont saint
bénézet nous sommes ici voici les
immeubles de classer les sites classés
les secteurs sauvegardés
les périmètres de protection
quand on baigne dans les patrimoines ont
fini par oublier la maintenant vous avez
un indicateur à l'échelle de la ville à
la pensée à l'échelle de la région de la
france de l'europe du monde
ce que vous voyez à l'écran est la carte
du patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
penser que chacun de ces sites est
probablement composer des dizaines
d'édifices historiques et certains de
ces édifices conserve à l'intérieur des
centaines d'objets d'art sans compter
tous les documents les textes les images
les gravures qui concerne l'histoire des
objets et qui sont aujourd'hui conservés
dans des bibliothèques ou dans des
musées sans compter tout ce qui est dans
les réseaux
on va des musées et qui n'est même pas
si c'est bon imaginons d'arriver à
concevoir des technologies ou des
machines capables d numériser tout ça à
tout le monde d'aujourd'hui pensent
qu'ils sa règle de le faire pensez vous
que ce serait vraiment suffisant pour
transmettre des connaissances sur le
patrimoine aux générations futures
on a bien vu que ce n'est pas la
modélisation numérique qui était l'âme
du projet c'est plutôt le système
d'interaction humains les croisements
d'observation qui permet de produire des
connaissances qui prouve permet de les
transmettre aux générations futures
la véritable question est donc comment
peut-on capter mémoriser ses
observations comment peut-on leur ailier
de façon stable aux objets du patrimoine
au travers des technologies numériques
c'est une question sur laquelle notre
laboratoire travaille depuis des années
et nous y travaillons en essayant
d'inscrire le développement des
technologies numériques dans la
continuité historique des méthodes
d'observation et de mémorisation que
l'homme n'a jamais cessé de développer
c'est à dire que nous essayons de
laisser radio pénétrer la technologie
dans notre quotidien et que les faits
sont de façon spontanée dans notre
quotidien
quand on veut enregistrer c'est que nous
observons nous prenons une photo une
photo capture l'instant temporel d'un
objet photographier mais où photo est en
même temps les témoins qui nous étions
la face à cet objet au même instant une
photo c'est bien plus une photo c'est
également notre regard sur l'objet
si vous y pensez bien c'est encore plus
vrai ça c'est probablement un choix des
transmissions
nous n'y prêtons pas attention plus
attention à chaque fois que nous prenons
une image c'est un choix de
transmissions qu'une fois ci en fait
combien des personnes à la salle dispose
d'un téléphone muni d'un appareil photo
vous pourriez s'il vous plaît avant de
rentrer à la maison ce soir prendre
quelques images de monuments de la vigne
on tue par le palais des papes les rend
pas faux mais dire oui on construisit
mais vous pouvez aussi vous demandez à
quoi ça pourrait servir façon un tout
petit pas en arrière dans l'histoire
cela fait des siècles que l'homme
recherche des solutions pour mémoriser
pour enregistrer leurs ailes il suffit
de penser à la perspective perspectives
à la caméra obscura tous des procédés
géométriques et des machines qui
anticipe et l'invention de la
photographie et c'est bien c'est
parcours qui démarre par la géométrie et
qui arrive à l'optique qui a donné un la
photographie la possibilité d'être
considéré immédiatement comme un outil
pour extraire des mesures durables
je vous demande juste type et
d'attention pour une gestion des trente
secondes pas plus un point sur une image
peut se trouver n'importe où dans
l'espace mais il sera toujours le long
d'une demi droite qui démarre d'un point
d'observation et se projette à l'infini
si nous disposons d'une deuxième image
du même objet nous pouvons extraire la
coordonnées spatiales de sept points par
intersection des deux mains droites
c'est à dire que si nous avons au moins
deux photographies du même objet nous
pouvons les construire sa géométrie
point par point il s'agit des bases de
la photogrammétrie c'est un chant qui a
beaucoup évolué dans les dernières
années
dernièrement et s'est mariée aux
avancées de la vision par ordinateur et
qui nous permet aujourd'hui des calculs
et des scènes très dimensionnelle à
partir de simples photographies des
façons complètement automatique et dans
les moindres détails pensé qu' il suffit
à peu près une centaine d'image pour
nous
risée des façons complètement
automatique la fontaine du cloître
saint-jean de la chartreuse de
villeneuve-lès-avignon une centaine
d'image tout le monde pour les acquérir
quand j'ai dit tout le monde j'entends
bien tout le monde ici vous voyez une
image une foule qui attend l'élection du
pape à rome en 2005 et en 2013 oui et
bien différente
vous comprenez mieux pourquoi je vous ai
demandé d'aller prendre des
photographies ce soir parce
qu'aujourd'hui la photographie qui était
un dispositif technologique d'exception
est dans les mains de tout le monde
c'est une véritable marée d'image qui
est acquise à chaque instant sur la
planète
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui où tous
nous pouvons grâce à une simple
photographie contribué et apporté une
pierre à la construction de la mémoire
numérique de ces objets mais parce que
les numériques nous permet aujourd'hui
d'explorer en profondeur les relations
qui existent entre une scène très
dimensionnelles et tout c'est possible
projection bidimensionnel c'est à dire
que on peut explorer la relation qui va
des pus à l'objet réel jusqu'à sa
numérisation mais également des
puissants numérisation jusqu'à l' objet
réel
la réalité se retrouvent donc augmentée
par sa dimension numérique et c'est là
qu'est une simple photographie votre
photographie devient la porte d'entrée
dans cette dimension d'information c'est
comme si des centaines d'années la
prévention de la perspective de la
photographie cette projection qui relie
l'oeil d'un observateur à l'objet
observé dvd une voix des transmissions
d'informations voie qui permet de mettre
en relation tous ceux qui observent un
objet mais également tous et peut
observer de cet objet dans les passes et
et ce qu'ils observeront dans les
futures
en cumulant des centaines des milliers
des millions des photographies de façon
participative
c'est comme si construisions une sorte
d'épiderme numérique autour des objets
une épiderme et qui est capable
d'observer les observations les
annotations les commentaires les
connaissances de tous ceux qui
contribuent à l'argumentation de ces
objets c'est comme si l'objet réel grâce
à sa peau numérique devenait en quelque
sorte la des moeurs des informations et
des connaissances et les concernant
c'est comme si chaque objet devenait le
théâtre dé sa propre mémoire construire
une plateforme numérique des
documentations participative du
patrimoine est un enjeu pour tout le
monde est allongé pour les
professionnels du patrimoine qui
pourrait collecter analyser
l'information et la partager avec un
collègue
c'est un enjeu pour les conservateurs
les administrateurs des sites qui
pourrait réunir et archiver ses
informations pour le monitorage de
l'état dé conservation des biens c'est
un enjeu pour les touristes qui pourrait
à la fois contribuer mais bénéficier
bien entendu d'une information
extrêmement riche et déclinable en
fonction des différents niveaux
d'approfondissement c'est un enjeu pour
les enseignants et les étudiants qui
pourraient contribuer à la construction
d'une ressource pédagogique collective
c'est un enjeu enfants pour les
scientifiques qui pourraient bénéficier
d'un saut quantitatif extraordinaire
pour analyser comparer corrélés des
masses des fragments d'informations à
très grande échelle et scénario régime
oppressant n'est que mon rêve des
chercheurs même si je peux vous assurer
que nous travaillons dur pour aller dans
cette direction
nous avons déjà un prototype de
plateformes numériques que nous comptons
mettre à disposition des premières
utilisateurs dans les prochains mois je
peux vous anticipez que cette plate
forme s'appelle aïoli vous savez nous
savons déjà qu'est ce que nous allons
faire dans les dix prochaines années
bien entendu mais le véritable défi
n'est pas la conception le développement
d'une nouvelle fonctionnalité pour
soufflante ondes en composants
technologiques très performant je pense
sérieusement que le véritable défi est
d'arriver à sensibiliser les gens à
l'importance de leur contribution
l'importance des comptes de fournir de
l'information pour constituer une grande
base des connaissances collectives
autour de nos patrimoines parce que
c'est toujours notre envie d'observer
des confondre de mémoriser et dé
transmettre notre passé notre quotidien
en générations futures qui traversera
les siècles et les technologies dans le
si beaucoup
[Applaudissements]